what happened outside and on the grounds
of the Chinese Consulate in Manchester
is now the center of a diplomatic
incident a pro-democracy protest by Hong
kongers started off peacefully but
banners and posters which the Chinese
say they found deeply offensive why
were torn down by officials including
the consul General
that led to a violent Clash which saw a
protester apparently dragged into the
consulate grounds and beaten by its
staff leaving him with cuts and bruises
on his body
but they are claims refuted by the
consul General inviting us inside to
share his version of events
Mr Zheng is one of China's most senior
diplomats in the UK and so this picture
showing him pulling the protester's hair
and dragging him into the consulate was
deeply troubling you know there was a
picture of you
pulling the protesters hair and dragging
him into the Consulate General into the
consulate grounds
do you think that's acceptable behavior
of a very senior Diplomat in the UK I
think it's an emergency situation that
guy is threatened my colleague's life
and in that day or we try to you know
control the situation
in a letter sent a greater Manchester
police the consul General said he was
disappointed that they didn't do more to
help and so his staff had to take action
into their own hands
I don't attack anybody
I'm the peacefully just that's not true
there is a console General you you
pulled the man's hair yeah the man is
because he's abused the country might
either
I think he's a it's my duty
to pull his hair yeah I think it's an
early diplomats if I face to such kind
of the behavior
Mr Chang said some of his staff were
injured too video footage shows a man
allegedly from the consulate being
kicked by protesters whilst on the floor
Bob Chan fled Hong Kong for his safety
but on Sunday he found himself at the
center of this clash in the UK he told
us he thought he might die
but it did happen here and is an issue
which is now on the agenda of the
foreign secretary it'll be down to
police to decide if any criminal justice
action is needed and for the government
to determine whether there are
diplomatic consequences into man Rashid
Sky News Manchester